.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Ich bin Morena Diaz, 27,
Lehrerin und Bloggerin.
Und ich wurde 2018
von einem guten Freund vergewaltigt.
Mein Name ist Luisa, ich bin 21
Jahre alt, Schauspielschülerin.
Und ich habe sexuelle Gewalt erlebt.
Ich bin Jorinde Wiese,
ich bin 25 Jahre alt,
Studentin, Aktivistin, Bloggerin.
Und ich habe mit 19 Jahren
sexualisierte Gewalt erlebt
und wurde oral vergewaltigt.
Mein Name ist Mabelle, ich bin 24,
Mama von zwei Kindern und Bloggerin.
Und ich wurde als 13-Jährige von
einem Gleichaltrigen vergewaltigt.
* Eindringliche hohe Klänge *
Hallo zusammen.
Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch:
Ich habe letztes Jahr eine Story
zum Thema sexuelle Gewalt gemacht.
Ich habe erzählt, dass ich das
mit 13 auch erlebt habe.
Ich war überwältigt
von den Rückmeldungen.
Ich habe mich letzten November
entschieden,
meine Geschichte auf Instagram
zu teilen - öffentlich für jeden.
Da ich in den letzten Jahren
oft damit konfrontiert worden bin
und ich immer wieder spüre und höre,
dass Frauen solche Dinge erleben
und nicht den Mut haben,
darüber zu sprechen.
Er hat mich vergewaltigt.
Das kann ich jetzt, nach zehn
Jahren, ganz klar aussprechen.
"Vergewaltigung, ein Thema, welches
auf Instagram nichts verloren hat."
"Etwas, wofür wir Opfer
von sexuellem Missbrauch
uns schämen müssten."
"Es geht doch niemanden etwas an,
dass du und andere
vergewaltigt wurden."
Bei mir war es so, dass mich
dieser Schulfreund verfolgt hat -
vorher schon.
Dann kam der Tag X,
an dem ich im Schwimmbad war.
Er war auch dort.
Deshalb fühlte ich mich unwohl.
Nach ca. 1 Std. entschied ich mich,
nach Hause zu gehen.
Ich entschied mich bewusst,
einen anderen Nachhauseweg zu nehmen
als den gewohnten.
Er folgte mir natürlich trotzdem.
Er hielt mich
mit beiden Händen fest.
Ich versuchte mich zu wehren,
ich schrie.
Er meinte: "Hör doch einfach auf,
dann ist es schneller vorbei."
Nachdem ich mich so heftig gewehrt
und auch verletzt hatte,
an Scherben,
die auf dem Boden lagen,
entschied ich für mich:
Ich lasse es über mich ergehen,
dann ist es schneller vorbei und ich
kann nach Hause, wo ich sicher bin,
zu meiner Mutter, zu meiner Familie.
* Eindringliche monotone Klänge *
Beim Blogeintrag habe ich zum
ersten Mal meine Geschichte geteilt
und ... geschrieben,
weshalb wir endlich über
sexualisierte Gewalt reden müssen.
Ich habe mit einem Brief
an mich selbst angefangen.
"Liebe Jori, du bist 19 Jahre alt
und wirst in fünf Jahren
über deine Erlebnisse mit
sexualisierter Gewalt schreiben."
"Öffentlich."
"Es wird dir egal sein,
was die Leute denken,
weil du weisst,
dass du nicht alleine damit bist."
"Sexistischer Kackscheisse hast du
bis dahin den Kampf angesagt."
Ich war damals 19 Jahre alt
und in einem Workcamp in Dänemark.
Und ...
Der Täter war im Endeffekt
einer aus der Gruppe,
mit dem ich mich sehr gut verstanden
habe und zu dem ich Vertrauen hatte.
Er hatte irgendwann die Idee,
im Wald spazieren zu gehen.
Ich fand das cool,
mal von der Gruppe wegzugehen.
Ich habe mir
ehrlich nichts dabei gedacht.
(Audioaufnahme)
Du hast einen Plan im Kopf.
Ich schaue mich um und sehe Bäume.
Blätter. Wald. Ich laufe locker.
Denke: "Bald, bald küsst du mich."
"Vielleicht. Wer weiss. Oder wir
laufen nur im Wald im Kreis."
Irgendwann ist er stehengeblieben,
hat mich angeschaut
und mich auf Französisch gefragt,
ob ich ihm einen blasen will.
Ich war total überfordert
von der Frage,
weil ich die
nicht hatte kommen sehen.
Er hat dann ziemlich schnell
meinen Kopf genommen
und mich festgehalten,
während er mich penetriert hat.
(Audio) Mund auf, Penis rein,
und ich schaue dir zu,
wie du von oben stehend
mich penetrierst,
wie du mehr und mehr
die Kontrolle verlierst.
Deine Hände sind fest um meinen
Kopf, meine Lippen um deinen ...
Es war für mich als die, die das
erlebt hat, total widerlich,
weil ich einen Würgereiz hatte
und kaum Luft bekam.
Ich habe mich dann irgendwie
irgendwann von ihm weggezogen,
als er gekommen ist,
weil ich das total eklig fand.
Und ...
Ich war danach irgendwie
total überfordert mit der Situation.
Ich habe sehr arg versucht,
das mit mir selbst auszumachen.
Ich habe versucht,
das unter der Dusche wegzuwaschen.
Ich glaube,
das geht auch einigen Opfern so.
Was natürlich nicht viel bringt.
Ich bin halt damit
eher alleine geblieben.
Nachdem das passiert war,
ging ich nach Hause.
Meine Mutter
stand bereits vor der Türe,
sie hatte versucht, mich anzuru-
fen, aber ich hatte mein Hany nicht.
In dem Moment, als ich ankam,
wollte sie mich suchen gehen.
Sie traf mich so an.
Ich stand unter Schock.
Ich war blutverschmiert,
brachte kein Wort heraus,
ich heulte nur.
Sie reagierte sofort
und fuhr direkt zur Polizei mit mir.
Unmittelbar nach der ganzen Sache
versuchte ich einfach,
das zu überspielen.
Ich funktionierte.
In der Schule hatte ich
so viele wichtige Dinge,
dass ich mir gar nicht die Zeit
nahm, um das zu verarbeiten.
Wir befanden uns gerade
in der Berufswahlphase.
Mir war es extrem wichtig,
weitermachen
und meine Lehre
absolvieren zu können.
Ich meine, so eine Lehre ...
... ist für die Zukunft
einfach wichtig.
Das war damals aktuell.
Ich befasste mich so intensiv damit,
dass ich das
einfach komplett ausblendete.
Vielleicht habe ich das
auch bewusst gemacht,
um das nicht immer im Kopf zu haben.
* Eindringliche Klänge *
Ich hatte Angst
vor dem seelischen Schmerz.
Ich habe ...
dem Ganzen bewusst ...
keinen Raum gegeben.
Die Erinnerungen
kamen jeden Tag hoch.
Manchmal konnte ich sie
gut beiseite schieben,
manchmal weniger gut.
Der Schmerz war immer da.
Das ist er heute noch und wird es
wohl auch noch lange sein.
"Drei Tage vor Heiligabend
wurde ich vergewaltigt."
"Nicht von einem Fremden,
nicht auf dem Heimweg,
nicht in einer dunklen Gasse,
sondern in den vier Wänden
eines 'Freundes'."
Wir hatten auch schon bei ihm einen
Film geschaut, was kein Problem war.
Dann schauten wir diesen Film -
mit einem ziemlichen Abstand:
Ich sass ganz links,
er ganz rechts.
Er fragte immer wieder, ob ich
nicht etwas näher kommen könne.
Ich sagte: "Nein,
für mich passt dieser Abstand."
Dann ...
Ja ...
Nach dem Film
fiel er ziemlich bald über mich her.
Ich hatte ihn plötzlich vor mir,
auf mir.
Dann ging es los.
Ich war sehr schockiert,
ich hatte es nicht erwartet.
Am Anfang versuchte ich,
ihn wegzustossen.
Ich versuchte, seinen Kopf
wegzustossen, dann seine Schultern.
Aber ich merkte schnell, dass ich
ihm komplett unterlegen war.
Und nicht nur das - mein Körper
resignierte plötzlich von selbst.
Ich spürte weder Arme noch Beine,
nichts.
Ich hätte mich am liebsten
weiterhin gewehrt,
aber ich konnte
einfach nichts mehr spüren.
Ich konnte nichts mehr bewegen.
Dieses Gefühl ...
Ich hatte wirklich ein bisschen
das Gefühl, neben mir zu stehen.
Ich habe schon alles
sehr direkt mitgekriegt, aber ...
Ich habe mich
sehr machtlos gefühlt.
Gut, da waren zum Einen
die Hände um meinen Kopf, aber ...
Mein Körper hat irgendwie
einfach mitgemacht und funktioniert.
Der Handlungsspielraum war da.
Das ist auch eines der Dinge,
die mich fertigmachen,
weil so vieles
hätte anders laufen können.
Hat es aber nicht.
Ich glaube, das ...
sehen viele Menschen sehr falsch.
Sie denken:
"Hättest du dich gewehrt ..."
Es ist sehr einfach, das zu sagen,
wenn man es nicht erlebt hat.
Wie stark muss sich eine Frau wehren,
damit Sex gegen ihren Willen
strafbar ist?
Sehr aktiv.
Sie muss wirklich
körperliche Gegenwehr leisten,
muss schreien, beissen,
auch ganz laut kundtun,
dass sie das nicht will.
Oder flüchten -
oder was auch immer.
Man muss beweisen,
dass die Frau das getan hat?
Ja, sie muss
mind. glaubhaft darlegen können,
dass sie das getan hat.
Und sie muss dazu auch etwas sagen.
Es reicht nicht, dass sie sagt:
"Ich habe ja Nein gesagt."
Das reicht nicht.
Das ist wie eine Faust ins Gesicht,
wenn einem gesagt wird: "Hey, du
hast dich einfach zu wenig gewehrt."
"Deshalb bist du selber schuld."
Das höre ich ständig.
Praktisch jeden Tag muss ich
unter meinen Beiträgen lesen,
ich sei selber schuld,
weil ich mich zu wenig lange
oder zu wenig heftig gewehrt habe.
Ich muss einfach sagen: "Nein!"
(Videoaufnahme) Die Gesetze,
wie sie heute sind,
machen ganz klar, dass die Opfer
weiterhin eine Mitschuld tragen.
Und ich weigere mich - für mich und
alle Opfer -, das zu akzeptieren.
Ich sammle auf Instagram
alles mögliche Aktivistische,
auch zu den Themen Vergewaltigung
und sexualisierte Gewalt.
Dieses Bild entstand, als ich
merkte: Es gibt keinen Weg zurück.
Die Flashbacks waren sehr präsent.
Dann habe ich mich
auf die Suche gemacht.
Habe mehr gebloggt und gepostet.
Nur wenn wir reden,
können wir uns sehen und verbinden
und uns gegenseitig stärken.
Gerade im Moment passiert so viel.
Es gibt extrem viele Menschen,
die reden, viele mutige Frauen.
Und ...
Ich glaube, die Veränderungen
sind in vollem Gange.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wenn ich
meine eigene Geschichte erzähle,
sind Menschen da, die mir zuhören.
Wenn ich mich sonst einsetze,
was ich ein Jahr lang
auch versucht habe,
ohne zu sagen,
dass ich selbst betroffen bin,
schlägt es nicht gleich hohe Wellen.
Ich bekomme nicht gleich viel
Aufmerksamkeit für das Thema.
Ich ging wirklich mit dem Ziel raus,
dass es thematisiert wird.
* Applaus *
Dann gab es einen Poetry-Slam.
Er drehte sich um Feminismus
und empowernde Dinge.
Ich dachte so:
"Das ist genau
die richtige Plattform,
um meine Geschichte
mal laut zu teilen."
Da waren extrem viel Angst
und richtig Panik in mir.
Ich habe meine Geschichte zum ersten
Mal laut erzählt, vor Menschen,
auf einer Bühne.
Deine Hände sind fest um meinen
Kopf, meine Lippen um deinen ...
Ich frag' mich gerade,
wie du das gut finden kannst,
dass ich hier vor dir knie,
ohne das wirklich zu wollen.
Dass du mich penetrierst und dabei
nicht kapierst, dass es eklig ist,
das in den Hals zu stecken, dass es
krass ist, das nicht zu checken.
Ich war danach einfach erleichtert,
dass es draussen war.
Als eine der ersten Reaktionen kam
an dem Abend eine junge Frau zu mir,
die nur mit mir sprechen wollte.
Sie schaute mich an
und meinte: "Danke."
"Das war meine Geschichte."
Dann weinte sie.
Ich dachte nur so: "Krass!"
"Wie viele sind hier, die diese oder
eine ähnliche Geschichte haben?"
Ich war 15 Jahre alt.
Ich hatte jemanden kennengelernt,
den ich auch total toll fand.
Wir waren wirklich so.
Wir haben uns
irgendwie alles erzählt.
Es war richtig schön.
Ich habe der Person auch vertraut.
Aber ich hatte so einen ...
Der war gleich alt wie ich.
Es war so: Ich habe ihm gesagt,
ich wolle ihn nicht küssen,
als er das versucht hat.
Dann hat er es zuerst gelassen.
Dann wieder und wieder probiert.
Irgendwann
hat es ihm quasi gereicht.
Er ... wollte sich von mir
nicht so zurückweisen lassen
und hat mein Nein übergangen.
Er hat mich einfach angefasst,
obwohl ich es nicht wollte.
Irgendwann lag ich so da,
die Hände rechts und links vom Kopf,
er hat sie festgehalten,
er lag auf mir,
versuchte mich zu küssen,
zog mich aus,
sagte mir, was ich tun müsse,
was alles meine Schuld sei.
Er schlug mich auch.
* Eindringliche sphärische Klänge *
Ich erlitt früher zwei bis drei
oder mehr Panikattacken pro Woche.
Mittlerweile geht es mir
eigentlich sehr gut mit dem Thema.
Ich kann auch wieder
körperliche Nähe erleben,
ohne Panik zu bekommen.
Ich weiss mittlerweile einfach:
Die Schuld an dem, was passiert ist,
liegt in der Psyche des Täters,
in den Problemen, die er
in seinem Leben evtl. hatte -
und mit seinem Kopf.
Die Verantwortung für das Geschehene
liegt beim Täter. Und nicht bei mir.
* Eindringliche Klänge *
Einfach weil nach der Tat
in mir so ein Ekel war,
war auch viel Scham da.
Jeder Mensch, der mal zu sexuellen
Handlungen gezwungen wurde,
kennt wohl dieses Gefühl von Scham.
Es ist ein ekliges Gegühl.
Die Scham ist sogar darüber da,
dass ich das erlebt habe
und dass ich das mitgemacht habe.
Ich hatte es so satt,
dass niemand darüber spricht,
weil ich selbst so darunter litt,
dass niemand Bescheid wusste.
Das hat sich so in mir angestaut,
dass ich gesagt habe:
"Ich will etwas tun."
Das Beste ist, den Mund aufzumachen
in Bezug auf Dinge,
die ich selber erlebt habe.
Sobald ich angefangen hatte,
über das Erlebte zu sprechen,
kamen immer mehr Menschen,
auch aus meinem Freundeskreis,
die sagten: "Luisa,
mir ist das Gleiche passiert."
Plötzlich bekommt man die Resonanz:
Es sind doch sehr viele Menschen.
Trotzdem macht keiner den Mund auf,
es wird nicht darüber gesprochen.
Das kann ja nicht sein.
Das ist, was ich erreichen will.
Hier habe ich
etwas für eine App gedreht.
Das ist ein bisschen ...
Ich mache etwas anderes.
Im Anschluss an das letzte Video
habe ich heute
ein paar richtig geile Sätze,
die man nach einem Missbrauch
zu hören bekommt.
Die könnt ihr 1:1 übertragen
auf jemanden mit einer körperlichen
Wunde, um ihn aufzuheitern.
Das funktioniert auch da super.
Ich zeig's euch:
Hey, was ist denn mit dir passiert?
Ben hat mir neulich
einfach so den Oberarm gebrochen.
Nein ...
Nein, Ben doch nicht. Ich kenne den.
Der würde so etwas niemals machen.
Das musst du
falsch verstanden haben.
Aber du siehst doch ...
Hä? Ich dachte, du mochtest den.
Ihr habt euch doch gut verstanden.
Ja komm ...
Mit der Nummer willst du
doch echt nur Aufmerksamkeit, oder?
Rein gesellschaftlich gesehen
finde ich es absolut begrüssenswert,
dass man
wieder mehr darüber spricht,
dass solche Fälle
auch publik werden.
Ich begrüsse auch
die ganze #MeToo-Kampagne,
die eigentlich bereits 2006
von Tarana Burke gegründet wurde.
Sie sagte, sie wolle
das Grabtuch der Scham lüften,
das über den vielen
unbekannten Opfern liegt,
die sexuelle Gewalt erlebt haben -
sei es Missbrauch in der Kindheit
oder sexuelle Gewalt
als erwachsene Frau.
Wenn es meine Klientinnen wären,
würde ich persönlich
natürlich davon abraten,
weil die Justiz -
Staatsanwaltschaft oder Gerichte -
das natürlich gar nicht mögen,
wenn man einen solchen Fall
zuerst öffentlich diskutiert
und dann allenfalls Anzeige
erstattet.
Jemandem, der sich überlegt,
Anzeige zu erstatten,
rate ich nicht zum Schritt
an die Öffentlichkeit.
Ich kann es aber nachvollziehen,
dass man dieses Bedürfnis hat.
V.a. wenn man denkt,
die Justiz versage sowieso.
Um eine Grenze zu setzen,
würde ich auf jeden Fall empfehlen -
um für sich, seine Bedürfnisse und
seine eigenen Grenzen einzustehen -,
Anzeige zu erstatten, unbedingt.
Für mich war es einfach ein Witz,
was die Folgen für ihn waren.
Er musste zwölf Sozialstunden
absolvieren für das,
was er mit angetan hatte.
Das ist ein Witz.
Deshalb würde ich es rückblickend
nicht mehr machen,
weil es sich nicht lohnt.
Es ist einfach nicht fair.
Es herrscht keine Gerechtigkeit.
* Eindringliche sphärische Klänge *
Was wird einem da genommen?
Sehr viel.
Ganz abgesehen
von meiner Jungfräulichkeit.
Das ist ein ganz anderes Thema.
Aber er hat mir vieles genommen:
das Vertrauen zu anderen Menschen,
ein Stück Freiheit,
das ist für mich das Schlimmste,
weil das heute noch präsent ist.
Ich kann keinen Aufzug benutzen.
Oder mit dem ÖV unterwegs zu sein,
bereitet mir extrem Bauchschmerzen,
wenn ich das so sagen darf.
Ich habe immer das Bedürfnis,
zu flüchten.
In geschlossenen Räumen
ist das nicht möglich.
Es war schon ziemlich heftig,
gewisse Reaktionen zu lesen.
Gewisse Kommentare
waren schon verletzend.
Ich hatte zwar damit gerechnet,
aber nicht in diesem Ausmass.
Ich sei selber schuld
aufgrund meiner Bilder.
Dass ich selber schuld sei,
weil ich diese Freundschaft
nicht beendet habe
oder zu ihm nach Hause ging.
Es wurden so viele Fragen gestellt,
die mir zeigten,
dass man primär nicht glaubt,
was das Opfer sagt.
"Opfer?
Sie sind eine feige Lügnerin."
"Unglaubhafte Schlampengeschichte."
"Und wer sich so präsentieren muss -
wen wundert's?"
Ich habe mir Gedanken gemacht über
das Bild, das ich posten möchte.
Was passt? Wie kann ich meine
Message am besten rüberbringen?
Ich wollte bewusst kein Bild posten,
das alle im Kopf haben.
Also ...
Man erwartet vom Opfer, dass es ...
Dass es sich schämt, traurig ist,
depressiv, dass es sich versteckt.
Und weiss nicht was.
Für mich war von Anfang an klar,
dass es ein Bild sein würde,
auf dem ich
eher leicht bekleidet bin.
Aus der Provokation oder der Message
heraus: Mein Körper gehört mir.
Ich könnte Nacktbilder posten -
er gehört immer noch mir.
Es hat niemand das Recht,
über meinen Körper zu entscheiden,
zu verfügen oder was auch immer.
Es darf nicht sein.
Man sollte sich als Opfer nicht mit
solchen Fragen herumschlagen müssen.
Man sollte keine Angst davor haben,
was andere denken könnten.
Schlussendlich
soll es kein Tabuthema sein.
Es geschieht jeden Tag irgendwo.
Ich finde,
man sollte offen darüber sprechen.
Ich habe es
in den zehn Jahren geschafft,
mich aus der Opferrolle zu befreien
und etwas Positives - sage ich jetzt
mal - aus dem Ereignis zu machen,
indem ich anderen helfen kann, ihnen
zeigen kann: Das Leben geht weiter.
Es ist sicher nicht einfach.
Und es braucht Zeit.
Es braucht wirklich Zeit.
Aber man schafft das.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Elisabeth Graf - 2020